[Music]
here we go again sony have revealed free
games we get as playstation plus
subscribers for the month of february
2022. you can grab the following games
from the first tuesday of the month
which this time is the first of february
so let's do this first up is tiny tina's
assault on dragon keep on the ps4 this
was originally dlc for borderlands 2
which was celebrated for doing something
a little different inspired by tabletop
rpgs and role playing it was all
tongue-in-cheek but due to how much
everyone loved it it's been made into a
standalone title with a fully fledged
game tiny tina's wonderland arriving
next month instead of being a secondary
character tiny tina takes center stage
and supplies commentary from the start
of the game all the way to the end tina
is weird in the best way possible and as
anything she dreams up can appear in
game it's definitely a game you need to
play to understand but saying that as
it's a borderlands game there are some
things you'll learn to expect ridiculous
story beats from dungeon master tiny
tina crazy enemy types to fight and so
many weapon variations you'll not know
which one to pick keep in mind this was
originally a dlc so don't expect a long
game about five hours is likely the
limit here i do recommend it and if you
do like it the next one around six times
bigger is only one month away next up on
the ps5 is planet coaster console
edition a management and construction
simulator in which we build our own
theme park in sandbox mode the world is
our oyster with unlimited funds to spend
we can build any and every ride or
attraction we like whereas career mode
asks you to bring a failing park up to
standard and compete for visitors as
we've been in lockdown for a few years
this could be a good way to get out of
the house without getting out of the
house we'll be doing all the undesirable
jobs too like monitoring litter in the
park and hiring handymen and janitors
too simon management games are quite a
niche genre but as it's free my advice
is always give it a try you never know
this might be your type of game you just
never tried it before and finally back
on the ps4 is ufc 4 a fight fest with
notable improvements from previous games
in that series ufc is all about fighting
prows mastering many forms of mixed
martial arts ufc 4 has attempted to make
the game easier on new players but it
still retains the crazy level of depth
for pros 2. the grappling system has
been refined with assisted transitions
and the career mode has been overhauled
to feel more like a genuine career path
of a professional with training for
fights while assessing your next
opponent as this is an ea game there
have been issues no doubt for example
they once added in-game adverts forcing
us all to watch luckily like other
things ea introduced this has now been
removed and they apologized for it
there's over 200 fighters to choose from
and a new commentary team to call the
shots ufc 4's reviews average at 8 out
of 10 so it's worthy of our time so
that's our games for february 2022 what
you're thinking please do me a favor and
review them in the comments below i'm
adam you're awesome i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you